so i worked at the hospital i went back
and got a job as an orderly and the
orderly
in a hospital i learned is they're the
least trained person there's no training
they go here's how you make a hospital
bed and you have to bring the patient
water you're on an eight-hour shift and
you have to take care of like say seven
or eight patients making sure they're
okay and you do anything water you need
your bed made if they poop in the bed
you gotta clean it you've got to clean
people's poop yeah they wipe their butts
no you didn't yes and i'm doing the
cartoon the critic and they go well is
it better doing the critic than than
being an orderly you go no it's much
better wiping people's butts than doing
voiceovers of course it's better so
anyway
there's not much that isn't better so so
did you know that you had the white
people's butts when you took the job no
how did you find out
they go you got to clean it up
and one one one it's horrible one woman
this is
anyway she was really sick you know and
she couldn't control her so she went to
the bathroom in her bed and it was like
it was like two it was horrible it was
like two giant balls of chili
so you had to get a towel
a big towel and scoop it up and put it
in the trashcan
yeah i scooped it up and it and i put in
the trash can and it was like sliding
out of the trash can and i was started
to throw up why didn't you put it in the
oh my god so i ran out of the room and
i'm gagging you know threw up and there
was a nurse cheryl big she's about huge
she's like six two
you know 200 300 pounds i go cheryl i i
i i can't do it i can't go back in i'm
gonna throw up
just john
it's your job just take a deep breath
and go back in
wow that's a good word and i was like oh
why would you clean the [ __ ] like two
bowls of chili of [ __ ] and why would you
dump it in the waste paper basket it was
so much
it was a giant amount
but isn't it too much
it was i was 21 i'll never forget it i
can't get out of my head
so there was so much
you couldn't just like wipe it it was
like a bowl of
chili
and the one it was hot i felt bad for
her but it was just but not oh my god
so then and then it goes is it better
being doing the critic of voiceover than
being an orderly
no no no it's much better wiping
people's butts no but you didn't you
didn't talk about that so now you clean
one woman had a stroke okay
you want to hear about this yeah
i'm just saying you're not a 22 year old
not qualified you're with the patient to
wipe it out more than anybody they start
thinking you're the doctor they get
emotionally dependent on you nobody has
a doctor wipe their ass no i'm telling
you they started going dr john doctor
john they thought i was the doctor of
these women they're in there
one woman was she had a stroke right
horrible anyway she's like in her 70s
i'm like 22 and she's going to the
bathroom oh no howie jesus
so
so i'm like waiting for her to push out
of do right
so she can't
do it because she has a stroke so she's
like this
it wasn't i felt that she's like i
laughed over it
she's like that pushing for like five
minutes and i'm waiting and i'm waiting
and i'm getting hot and i'm yelling at
her come on push
go ahead will you push
and it's coming out like a millimeter at
a time
her poop i'm like wait you know what i'm
saying i'm saying i'm not i wasn't good
i wasn't qualified but you you blame
yourself for her inability no i i'm
saying i i was a jerk for being
impatient is what i'm saying oh do you
this is an apology yeah i'm just like
you were yelling at her
will you push
[Music]
bye